welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Jessica Clemens and this is the
breakdown of Netflix's newest live
action adaptation of One Piece I've
talked with so many different people
about this live action and justifiably
we were all nervous when we first heard
about it the list of Western live action
adaptations of mangas and animes just
didn't live up to the hype but one piece
for me was a little bit different
whether it was the Charming characters
kooky attitude or just downright hot
actors in it I'm talking about buggy I
think a lot of it is in picking the
right material and never taking yourself
too seriously because then you can make
something for everyone to enjoy I really
liked one piece of live action and I
sparingly watched the anime because if
you don't know there's over 1 000
episodes so I've requested to tackle
this with my best friend Nick Murphy who
loves one piece more than anyone I know
we'll be coming from not only two
perspectives but we'll dive into the
stories behind the stories we see on
Netflix where this could be going in
season two and clearly the differences
in materials and before we dive in don't
forget to subscribe to the other
channels in the network at the break
room and the Deep dive and you can also
support the channel by checking out some
awesome merch options over at the
nerdriot.shop I haven't said that in so
long okay let's get into it one piece
follows a young pirate Monkey D Luffy
and his crew the straw hats as they
embark on a journey to find the
notorious one piece and become king of
the Pirates the first season of Netflix
adaptation covers the majority of the
East blue Saga which is basically the
introduction to one piece and the straw
hats one piece is broken up into major
sagas then sub sagas and those sub sagas
include a bunch of arcs that work sort
of like chapters so for instance the
East blue Saga covers anime episodes 1
through 61 where we go through a bunch
of arcs the romance Dawn Arc orange Town
syrup Village barati arlong and the log
Town Arc though we never actually make
it to the log Town Arc the ending
alludes to someone who shows up in the
log Town Arc spoilers it's a Luffy's
antagonist smoker a marine captain and
log Town who can control and turn into
smoke after consuming the plum Plum
fruit I break down what episodes of the
anime are covered in what episodes of
the live action but that doesn't mean
everything is the same they actually
took some Liberties and different
approaches to make it better for TV
though a lot can be said in tandem with
the anime it really was the creator of
One Piece Ichiro Oda that made the live
action a reality they had a hard time
building out the characters and their
emotional arcs that work in TV so they
went back to Ichiro's SBS chapter notes
where he answered fan questions I
explore character backstories and what
they want it also helps when Ichiro and
his team assist along the way he acted
as a guard dog to ensure the material
was being adapted in the correct way
this was covered in an interview with
the New York Times there were numerous
scenes that the production agreed to
reshoot because he didn't feel like they
were good enough to put out into the
world this feels like the same control
Neil druckman had in the last of us that
made it so successful it's nice having
the creative control or just massive
Insider knowledge when needing to tweak
things in the material because it's
coming from the source itself also you
know
ichirota is literally higher than like
the goat so he wasn't going to let
anything just like fly without his
permission right I'd also like to add
because it's been in controversy lately
but the nationalities of the straw hats
are diverse and Oda answered this
question ages ago in an SBS it also
makes sense because they're literally
traveling the world picking up different
people and just being Pirates so Luffy
is from Brazil zoro's from Japan Nami is
Swedish usop is from Africa don't get me
started and Sanji is French there's also
other straw hats that we haven't met yet
like the Dr chopper from Canada and the
skeleton musician Brooke who's Austrian
across the first season we expand on the
origins of the straw hat crew though the
first episode covers half of the romance
Dawn Arc which for the anime is covered
in episodes one through three this is
the first story arc of the Mangan which
both Luffy and zoro's past were revealed
but also where we met Kobe and Zorro
becomes his first mate technically we
don't meet Nami here but they change
that for the live action at the
beginning we see the execution of gold
Roger and in the anime we get a similar
scene just not with Admiral GARP there
so we start to see how the show wants to
tether stories and weave them together
from the jump even at the beginning we
see some of our beloved older Pirates
like mihawk and Shanks just to remind
you that it's been years since the
execution next time we see the
characters and no one still has found
the one piece yet we meet our Monkey D
Luffy played by Naki Godoy who might be
my favorite casting ever this boy is
literally perfect when he met Ichiro Oda
and one of the most heartwarming promos
I've ever seen Ichiro said you're just
like the character I draw on the manga I
intuitively thought that's Luffy it made
me cry the first time I watched it Luffy
ate the devil fruit known as the gum gum
fruit with the gum gum fruit Luffy is
able to do more than just stretch his
limbs to outrageous proportions using
his fighting prowess Luffy is able to
manipulate his body into almost anything
imaginable his main moveset revolves
around a weapon-like Arsenal with moves
like the gum gum pistol where he
stretches his arm back to deliver a
bullet-like punch or gum gum Gatling
where he throws out a flurry of punches
and quick succession at his enemies
because his body is made of rubber blunt
objects have no effect on him Luffy is
also immune to all electricity based
attacks as Robert cannot conduct
electricity however like with all devil
fruit users Luffy's weakness is the sea
if he was thrown into the ocean he would
simply lose all his energy and his power
there are three categories of devil
fruits the zoens the logias and the
paramecius zones are typically based on
animals users of this fruit can either
completely transform into the creature
their fruit is based on or become a
hybrid Fusion Zone type devil fruits
aren't limited to humans only inanimate
objects such as swords can consume the
fruit even animals can consume the fruit
most notably done by the straw hats
resident Dr Tony Tony Chopper though
Reindeer chopperate the hedohedonomi
fruit which granted him the ability to
turn into a human reindeer hybrid logias
are based on natural elements like ice
water or like smoke you can manipulate
it or turn into those things logias are
considered to be one of the rarest and
most powerful types of devil fruits due
to the almost Godlike invulnerability it
grants the user users of this fruit have
complete control over a specific element
affecting the environment around them
because they can turn into the element
themselves almost any attack against
them is useless then there's the
paramecias which basically any other
ability you see that's not animal or
Elemental like Buggy's ability to split
into different parts though we don't
know the exact origin of the devil
fruits they are believed to be a
manifestation of humans hopes and
desires even if the devil fruit user
dies the fruit itself will simply
reappear again somewhere in the world
Luffy also looks up to Shanks who leaves
the red hair Pirates this isn't Luffy's
father but a great father figure the red
hair Pirates make their appearance
during flashbacks around Luffy's
childhood we also learned that usopp's
father yasap is a member of the
red-haired Pirates and I love him Shanks
and Luffy grow a strong bond Shanks even
loses his arm to the lord of the coast
the Sea King to save Luffy which sort of
mirrors Chef zeph's story and losing his
leg to save Sanji and nami's mother
sacrificing herself to save her
daughters this world is just like
chaotic horrendous parental tug of war
and it's like it kills me it's horrible
Luffy meets Kobe played by Morgan Davies
working with alvita and both the anime
and the live action Kobe is presented to
us as a small boy traumatized due to his
captivity under Pirates having to work
under Pirates goes against his dreams of
becoming a Marine Kobe is a very timid
and overly cautious young boy whose
conviction of his dream is strengthened
after meeting Luffy the live action does
a great job introducing Kobe to the
audience following much of the original
story and characterization of Kobe the
live action deviates though by giving
Kobe more Spotlight throughout the
series some of the story beats differ
from the original Kobe sees true to his
character and his goals of becoming a
strong Marine Kobe basically becomes a
supporting character playing the same
part as Luffy just for the Marines you
let me know what you think about his
continuing appearance because I really
like it we really get a glimpse at their
juxtaposed arcs as they both rise higher
in their own ranks being true to their
missions and to themselves we're
watching them both like grow up from
episode 1 until the end and I really
like keeping Kobe to help blow out the
world especially the Marines Kobe begins
working very closely with Marine vice
admiral GARP played by Vincent Reagan
who is perfect for the job he doesn't
appear until the 68th episode in the
anime though and isn't revealed to be
Luffy's grandfather until episode 314.
The showrunner Stephen maieda explained
one of the decisions that I made early
on was wanting to have an antagonist in
Pursuit and GARP seemed to lend himself
so well to the idea it was a change we
made in order to keep the Jeopardy up
and we feel like there were big stakes
and I really liked the decision because
the reveal was fun and stresses you out
as I said earlier having him there for
gold Rogers execution was good for
weaving the story and picking up the
pace for TV the events of Kobe and Hal
meepo training under GARP that takes
place over the course of the first
season of the live action actually are
only highlighted in a few one-off
episodes pre-time skip it isn't until
after the two-year time skip where Kobe
and halmipo are seen after their
transformation due to their rigorous
training one shot energy I'll I'll try
one I'll try one if it doesn't wake me
up I'm gonna be pissed
oh yeah
I know Kung Fu
[Music]
H
okay I'm gonna try the focus ones now
[Music]
[__]
okay one shot is really all I need I
think they both clashed in me and now I
don't know where I'm at begin your
transformation with one shot energy
today by going to one shotenergy.com new
rockstars for 10 off your order I am
going crazy I am an insane person I have
to go see a musical
let's go sit in a theater oh oh my God
as they arrive at shellstown movie meets
roronoa Zorro the pirate Hunter and Nami
the thief and I will call him Zorro
going forward I'm so sorry Nami played
by Emily Rudd is our Navigator when the
Manga and Anime is introduced in the
orange Town Arc the town taken over by
the buggy Pirates where she is chased by
Buggy's men after looting their treasure
and a map to the Grand line Luffy
crashes down from the sky and saves Nami
though she initially tricks Luffy into
becoming her captive and turning him
over to buggy in order to steal from him
further she soon teams up with the straw
hats in order to take buggy down not far
from the anime Nami was orphaned and
found by the Marine belmare who raised
her and her adoptive sister nojiko later
in her life we get the arrival of arlong
who demanded a fee for everyone living
in nami's Island when belmare used her
share to cover her daughters our long
ended up killing Vermeer shooting her in
front of Nami just like they do in the
live action Nami then begins working for
arlong's crew and made a deal with
arlong that for 100 million Barry she
would buy back her Village freeing
everyone which is why she's a thief and
hates Pirates Romano azoro was
introduced to them anime and manga
captured by axman Morgan and tied up in
the courtyard for a month without food
and water he makes it 20 days before
meeting Luffy who unties him and asked
him to join his crew to which he says no
and in the live action is basically the
same thing Zora refuses to join the
Marines and is to spend seven days to a
poll without food and water if he wants
to receive his Bounty then he's freed by
Luffy and asked to join his crew into
which he says no again we also learn in
a flashback his drive to be the best
swordsman come from his childhood friend
kuina in the manga this is shown in a
single flashback during the romance Dawn
Arc also can't ignore Mr Seven where it
was originally just alluded to in the
anime but we actually see it here they
both agreed a venture with Luffy though
it's later revealed nami's with a little
hidden agenda but regardless we then
slide into the rest of the romance Dawn
Arc in Orange Town Arc and meet
everyone's hot clown buggy
okay who arguably was still fine as hell
in the anime I'm standing my ground on
this one in this live action buggy drugs
and kidnaps the straw hats Luffy
swallows the map and buggy torches him
in search of it while Nami and Zoro are
held hostage in another part of the
circus tent they eventually break free
and Luffy defeats buggy as well as
setting all of Buggy's hostages free
then we slide into episode 3 that covers
the first half of the syrup Village Arc
which in the animes episodes 9 through
11. in sir Village we meet Usopp who
introduces the gang Takaya a sick
heiress under the care of a horrible
people scheming to take her riches
Amelia fans notice usopp's normal nose
and yes his long nose is gone the
showrunner thought it would be
unintentionally comical in a way that
would distract from the character and I
agree we also don't get the usop Pirates
the children inspired by usop who
pretended to be pirates in syrup Village
usop like in the anime had a father
yasep of the red hair pirates that left
when he was young and his mother died
from an unnamed illness young usop would
tell his mom's stories just like he told
Kaya and though they were lies they
cheered the two up unfortunately like
the boy who cried wolf no one in the
village believed him and when an
emergency did arise they still didn't
believe him this blends with episode 4
that covers the second half of the syrup
Village Arc where we really see the big
bad of Kaya's Mansion Kuro Kuro is
serving nothing but like he's given
Freddy Krueger and I love him Caro was
the captain of the black cat pirates
with two companions in the anime the
companions were brothers here they're
just colleagues also in the live action
they've been keeping Kaya sick instead
of just killing her by the hypnotist
Django who doesn't make an appearance in
this at all the fight between usop and
the straw hats and KIRO is much bigger
in the anime and the anime Usopp
actually has his own crew Kuro also has
more of his own crew involved in the
fight with a plan to actually kill them
to keep his true identity as a pirate
from ever being revealed this fact was
actually what motivated Luffy to defeat
Kuro as he was mad that any Captain
would ever think to do this to their own
crew Kai is captured by Django she
threatens to kill herself in order to
save usop's crew that are trying to
protect her but with his sniper skills
Usopp takes out Jenga and saves kaiyo of
course with the help from Zoro in the
live action their plan like blew up in
their face and they they were defeated
by the straw hats and usop then joined
as their newest member with their new
ship the going Mary named after Mary who
died by Kuro sorrow Sorrows prayers
prayers then we're taken to episode 5
that covers the first half of the
baryardi arc body artyark which for the
anime covers episodes 19-24 this is
where the gang arrived at barati and we
meet Sanji and both the live action and
Anime we meet Sanji apparati who is a
waiter hitting on NAMI that all Rhymes
much of the core aspects of Sanji are
represented well in the live action
Sanji is a cool Suave cook really the
biggest difference is the delusion of
just like how Love Struck he is by women
other than finding the all-blue women
are one of sanji's major motivations for
taking action there's even a time when
Sanji fully needed a blood transfusion
because he lost too much blood from a
nosebleed after meeting a bunch of
mermaids and this wasn't just a joke it
was actually a serious plot point that
spanned over a few episodes because
Sanji almost died from it this episode
was my favorite episode though episode 5
Luffy's as supportive and Loyalist Sanji
and it really feels like Luffy's been
teaching others every episode but he
starts to actually learn from this chef
not only do their Origins with their
mentors blend but so do their positive
optimistic outlooks where Kobe is like a
lawful version of Luffy Sanji feels like
that mature yet silly version of Luffy
while we made Sanji we also meet mihawk
and do I love mihaka maybe it's the
actor I don't know now when we're
introduced to mihawk he's killing a
well-known character Don Creek who
normally has a much longer life in the
barati arc but instead dies in the live
action immediately and his role is kind
of usurped by our long this was blessed
by Oda himself you guys they said it in
an interview with variety I'm sure this
was done just to tie into nami's story
and close out the first season and I'm
I'm sorry that he died so quickly drakul
Hawkeyes mihawk is one of the seven
Warlords of the sea pirates that are
basically granted a pardon by the
Marines in exchange for doing work for
them mihawk holds the title of being the
strongest swordsman in the world he's
one of the most serious characters in
all of One Piece rarely showing emotion
even when fighting because of his skill
and title he represents the ultimate
obstacle for Zorro who dreams of
becoming the strongest swordsman episode
6 covers the second half of the borati
arc after Zoro is defeated by mihawk and
arlong has tracked his way all the way
back to Luffy and his crew all thanks to
Buggy's ear stuffed into Luffy straw hat
in the anime the first time we see
arlong is at the kokiyashi Village when
Nami runs away to settle her debt in the
live action we're seeing them much
sooner Nami betrays luffia barati as she
decides to go back to the village with
arlong with the grand line map this is
when it's revealed to us that Nami is a
double agent for arlong but as I said
earlier when detailing nami's backstory
it's clearly all a front in the anime
arlong is depicted as a ruthless and
intimidating fish man with strong desire
for wealth and even stronger hatred of
humans just like me arlong believes that
humans are inferior to fishmen due to
their lack of strength and inability to
breathe underwater to him humans simply
are behind in evolution when compared to
fishmen our long has always held the
distaste for humans though initially it
was less targeted it wasn't until his
former Captain Fisher tiger was killed
that his hatred grew to the level that
it is now arlong's anger stemmed from
the enslavement of the Fishman which led
him to enslave humans himself episode 7
covers the first half of the arlong park
Arc where episode 8 covers the second
half this is where the straw has decided
to free the villagers and defeat arlong
and his men we get this heart-wrenching
scene of Nomi's money going to waste and
being betrayed by arlong and I hate it
everyone loves the walk to arlong park
and the anime and this scene is almost
shot for shot the same in the live
action not me covering her mouth the way
they're all waiting the three-way split
screen of right they do a lot of similar
shot by shots to the anime like Shanks
losing his arm to the Sea King and the
fight between mihawk and Zorro though
luckily the live action ends on a high
note as the gang defeats arlong frees
the villagers and it's revealed that
Luffy now has a major bounty on his head
while it's exciting to know that he's a
full-fledged pirate it's also daunting
that everyone in the East blue will be
looking for him to collect the straw
hats set sail for their grand line with
their newest flag in their next
adventure awaits eventually crossing
paths with smoker that's it for our
breakdown of season one of the
live-action adaptation of one piece and
I freaking liked it I loved it do I
think it broke the live action curse I I
don't know I have a weird relationship
with the live-action adaptation occurs
from video games to anime I do know that
this is my favorite Western live action
adaptation from a monger anime so far
and I want a second season I need second
season I'm so happy Ichiro Oda approved
and worked so closely on it without his
Visions we wouldn't have Luffy we
wouldn't have the years upon years of
One Piece content follow me at Lulu
underscore Clemons follow new rock stars
on all social media platforms and don't
forget to subscribe to the break room in
the Deep dive I'll see you guys later
I can't do the gum gum I can't do I
can't do it gum gum gum gum battling
[Laughter]
[Music]